if you love me
you love all of me
or none of me at all
that's lizzo bearing it all on tick-tock
teasing her new song i'm feeling good as
hell
the 33 year old singer goes nude while
giving fans a sneak peek at the track
about unconditional love if you love me
you love all of me
or none of me at all
in the caption lizzo opens up about the
lyrics explaining quote if you love me
you love all of me you don't get to pick
and choose we should be unconditionally
loving of one another starting with
being unconditionally loving to
ourselves take a moment today and think
about the conditions we hold so tightly
to that keep us from the freedom of true
love do you really want to be so tightly
wound free yourself in love you deserve
it i need this music to be my therapy
because i have been solo and i refuse to
you know live life like that anymore but
there's more the grammy winner has been
busy teasing her new music like this
song she previewed last month
[Music]
and no one's approval is more important
than her mom's that's the truth hurts
singer filming the moment when she first
played the tune for her
celebs like cardi b even shared their
love for the heartwarming video on
social media
girl what
and speaking of cardi
the new york native teamed up with lizzo
in august when they released their
up-tempo collab rumors
[Music]
and if fans get their way it won't be
the only duet on lizzo's new album
here's the t a track with bts could be
in our future so how how was it with
lizzo she's a very big fan of you guys
did you maybe have a chance to talk
possibly of maybe making some music
together with her it was so loud and
crazy and hectic there so we just uh
talk a little talk and and then had a
little photo shoot and then and then you
know we share
phone number
oh yeah yeah so that's what starts first
is you share a phone number then you
start texting then you get some music
together yes would that be something
you'd be interested in of course we're
so open she's a she's she's so fire i
mean everything she spits so far we'll
just be over here trying to manifest
that but until then let's enjoy lizzo's
uplifting and soulful new song one more
time
none of me at all
[Music]